sur la question de la création d'une
garde prétorienne à l'elysée n'en a
jamais été question
quelle que soit la réforme qui est menée
je rentrerai pas dans le détail les
personnes qui s'occuperont de la
sécurité du président de la république
seront toujours des policiers et des
gendarmes
cela va de soi et il est absolument
nécessaire et là aussi désolé de répéter
le terme ça va de soi qu'il y aura
évidemment toujours un lien avec le
ministère de l'intérieur puisque je
crois vous avoir expliqué que dans
l'organisation des déplacements
il s'agissait d'adjoindre les
compétences d'un service de sécurité
rapprochée qui est le j'espère et des
compétences plus vaste de gestion de
l'ordre public qui sont sous l'autorité
des préfets donc le lien il est
impératif si on veut réussir la sécurité
d'un président de la république en
déplacement